[Music]
we have a little update
since yesterday um and i feel like we
had now at this point we're in so we
have to play it
we have an update so last we left this
saga oh actually i you just reminded me
i forgot to send you something okay send
it
thank you jim
hold on what's in there what is in there
oh there she is
yeah
put that on the screen put it on the
screen no oh my god put that one on the
screen oh my god
okay sorry anyway
um which wait which one should i play
first should i should play mine first
because i think if we're gonna go in
terms of timing okay this this one i
think is so
apparently
uh dan soder and big j were doing the
bonfire
and somebody was recording on a hot mic
it there's a hot mic picking things up
[ __ ] and they were having an uh off the
air conversation you might have to turn
it up a bit but it's i figured
judas goats did the best to go with the
audio
all right let's see
the credits on rnd
you said this you said this you said
this none of this is true and he's like
yeah
yeah
she's just warm like a puppet dude it's
wild all over chang
they're busy in that kitchen dude orange
chicken's flying papa
[Laughter]
well he they're right everything they
said was a hundred percent correct yes
there's
dudes
orange chicken papa
that was [ __ ] very funny
all right so that's that part here's a
little bit of an update on uh the tell
tiger belly brian count thing okay
rock steady what's up buddy how you
doing pal how am i doing well i mean
listen you look no it's cool daddy got
some sleep daddy got some sleep rested
well i had to bobby's got some fans
bobby's got it and here's what's funny
uh they're a little mad at me but i'm
i'm a bobby fan so that's what's
interesting about this too and uh guys
it was a phone you normally yell at the
people that you're fans of and threaten
lawsuits on them without getting any
information from them i see i see your
side of this race but on the other hand
brian callan is always yelling mm-hmm
that's true that's true paul
we have to clear some stuff up i think
there's some misunderstanding people
weren't listening
i apologized immediately after and and
bobby and i spoke
and i he read me the riot act he's mad
at me i apologized way before any of
this i wasn't i didn't did this stuff
didn't happen and then i apologize i
apologize i like the day after i called
you called again yeah you sent a text
yeah you called it
yeah you called me you
let him finish oh yeah you did that no i
get it but i'm trying to tell the story
brandon oh thanks bubba i took the
bullet for you can i at least talk a
little bit you'll be what
oh no okay
i hate you
yeah i want this to be very clear it's
not like you're like man i'm getting a
lot of [ __ ] for this you were i mean i
apologize i found out two days after
you're like i talked to bobby i
apologize wow it's very rare that
someone is a phillies fan and a tampa
bay fan wow he's just a fan of every
baseball team yeah i don't think he's
gonna accept it but that's all i can do
yes i did i i i did everything i could
um i felt terrible
but i did not threaten listen the other
thing is people are saying i'm a bully
so i get it
you know it's all it's all good i i
didn't threaten i didn't say i was gonna
get goons i didn't threaten his life i
didn't threaten this family i did not do
that i i was yelling i was mad because i
i was defending my friend i was working
on information that i believed to be
true at the time but without asking him
my mistake was not giving him the
benefit of the doubt or talking to him
and and again i'm i apologize for that
but like like i'm a fan too i hey hey
i'm with you yeah like the movie the fan
more like that yeah probably bobby
that is a [ __ ]
low-key good movie that people always
always sleep on do not photoshop
brandon brennan trump do not photoshop
brian callan on that scene from the
bobby with bobby lee in it thank you
like i'm with you i was texting with
bobby this morning i'm like dude like
this is getting crazy like now at this
point i'm my mom he was texting with
bobby i thought bobby said he wasn't
going to talk to him anymore i my
family's getting threats of violence
like now it's gotten to the point where
my family my fiance with the you
threaten to send him to jail for crimes
so i mean i get it and it does suck but
let's you know
let's explain why
baby she's getting threats of violence
and she's afraid like it's it's fine
it's one thing if it's hate but also
guys i've been friends with bobby for a
forever yes he's mad at me i feel [ __ ]
bro
yes he's he oh we watched the tiger
belly episode he said i won't even say
his name
that's what bobby said i won't even say
his name [ __ ] terrible as far as the
death threats we had a conversation and
i oh welcome see brandon could couldn't
saw that welcome to club me also me too
so he kind of just reveals that he's an
[ __ ] and this is always
he's i guess owning it owned out
everything and he and he accepted my
apology he still pissed at me but he
accepted my apology and that was all way
before all this [ __ ] can i say
something
even with all this
i missed this dynamic that other fighter
in the kid thing did not work for me
this is fighter and the kid this is what
i want to see i want to see an angry guy
that's probably on trt
yelling at a dumb guy because he got hit
in the head too many times that's the
dynamic
but i apologize when i [ __ ] up i
apologize it's a matter of principle yes
that's who you are you have to own up to
it no matter what you know and and no i
i you know
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not a have a am i
a bully i mean have i ever done this no
don't hit me
am i a bully i don't know man because
you've told other stories about where
you a lot of stories have yeah gone
around about this [ __ ] guy about your
anger problem i mean again i i fighting
people yeah
you know i mean
yeah you kind of sound like a bully i
might my i got angry i was defending my
friend i got a little you know heated
and you're shoving a little heated is
not what you did
you threatened his entire life merch and
i have fights about business stuff out
there sometimes and we get a little
heated never have we involved the police
you know what i mean what threatened to
end the other one's career i know what
the [ __ ] bro
it's like okay you know what man [ __ ] it
whatever dude a green [ __ ]
disagreement that's him i'm [ __ ]
leaving i'm leaving i'm getting out of
here and then we're done yeah from time
to time i shoved you around a little on
once in a while yeah you shoved me in a
locker yeah but i stayed there but
what's [ __ ] crazy about this
is that
the people that are are mad at me
in a sick way it's like no no guys i get
it i love bobby too you don't love bobby
more than i love bobby no they do
because they never threatened to call
the police on him so just on that fact
alone they love bobby more than you
brian
i love bobby more than you i've never
threatened to end his career and again
i don't buy
i do not buy
that he was the only one involved in
this i just don't i'm not buying that
story
i get it i've i've known him for 25
[ __ ] years yeah he's one of the
sweetest funniest kindest people in the
100 percent that's why and why
i
that's why that's what i felt i felt
[ __ ] terrible
and i
tried to do everything in my power to
make it right way before this storm this
insanity and
he's like guys it was a phone call you
made a mistake you apologized you owned
up to it that's all you can do brother
that's all you can do
neither one of us handle the situation
right you know
i'm running for that congress
i'm i want to make this less like china
i'm pregnant job i'm not a vulcan glass
we're like in your life
there has been there has been really
really bad harassment and and
how
threats
of
for a very long time when your team
when your team sho
when i see what you're when your team
shows me
what i what i consider to be
what is this team who is this team his
team okay at least activity he he hired
he hired a
black cube
and long-term activity coming from that
area
that's what set me off and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on and i mean
i made them aware of that yeah they're
they're trying to get to the bottom i
will say that they're not like
no it's just like no but they are but it
hasn't stopped yeah yeah so and that's
all i wanted out of this that's not
suing or anything like that me and
kalyala takes each other today
yeah i just don't drop this [ __ ] you
know it's like this is not me i have no
ill will i do not want anything bad to
happen i love that guy of course you
don't you're the one that [ __ ] up i
know i this is like the equivalent of
when
like somebody yeah like somebody who
cheated is the one that's like can we
just drop it like why do we have to sit
here and harp on like old mistakes and
you're like this just happened yeah
it's like
you know it's like people that are
pieces of [ __ ] are always the ones that
are like come on man why do we gotta
live in the past you know it's like i
don't know i guess if your past is
terrible
okay let me tell you this too is like
it's over yeah that's done with i have
nothing but love for them you won't hear
a negative thing and nor have you heard
a negative thing about them on this
podcast and the ten thousand shows that
i've done no one says they didn't do
anything in any facet
but
there's like there's gonna be hate and
gossip and people love the podcast drum
stuff like that it's not what we
specialize in yeah
what do you specialize in
not comedy mindless babble get what do
you specialize in scrolling chicks
instagrams
i don't understand what is your speci
exactly going through exactly 100 marks
going through instagram and looking at
broads and butchering the english
language butchering the english language
that's their specialty nice
yeah we nor have we ever done that i i
never pay attention to it but when my
you do you've literally said that was
you you melted down over it you yelled
about us and said we don't play sports
like there's that but that those whoever
those extremists that are and take it
from a guy who's been has his black belt
in haters
what did he say
he has a black belt in haters no he
didn't say that there's no way an adult
man let me hear that again
he missed that earth and take it from a
guy who's been has his black belt in
haters i think
he has black belt in haters
brendan i don't believe you even had a
black belt in jiu jitsu
and you're a pro fighter maybe he did i
don't want to say that because he might
have i don't know pete might have you
know
it does i don't care it's still funny
it's still funny it is
shop
have a
brandon shaw has earned his black belt
in jiu jitsu yeah there you go yeah he
did from eddie bravo no no no from
houston bjj banner i don't know who that
is he gave that he brought bravo his old
uh raptor truck in in exchange for one
so before you start you delete the
people that are already typing in the
comments later for this clip they're
going like he actually you could stop we
know he does i have fine he has his
black belt in haters
and jiu-jitsu
what
yeah those extremists and those guys
doing that over-the-top [ __ ] they're the
minority yeah whoa bobby lee might be a
minority but you can't blame all of them
can i ask you something
is it worse
if you're a black belt
but you could probably get beaten up by
like purple belts
i mean i don't know i don't know what's
worse or not worse
you know they look like that
works be so is kaleidos so i'm not
everybody in here they're staff
everybody's loved but when you focus on
that
you can go down a very very dark road
and that's not reality yeah the in the
and also they're not gonna they're gonna
send those threats you know and
obviously but it's just
for me i can handle it's awful for a
woman with a baby at home she has
nothing to do with it trying to be
married to me the best person i'd be
married to me it's real
sounds like hell it sounds like hell
why would you want to do that
why would you want to do that to seeing
you struggle trying to tell siri
something or alexa something and it
doesn't understand you that sounds sorry
i didn't understand you
alexa
i'm sorry i do not understand alexa i
miss the blender
i'm sorry i still don't understand
it's like being married to the [ __ ]
joker yeah it's more than time the joker
no no no no no no no you do [ __ ]
stuff it's like being married to the
joker
what is he doing i don't know
and wait was it i thought the joker
was the guy who terrorizes everybody
right like who's terrorizing the joker's
family nobody
know what i mean
if the joker had a wife and kids who in
gotham would be like i'm gonna rape your
wife and kill your [ __ ] kids it's
like what are you doing you're just
instigating the joker
well i don't know how i got these brain
scars
it's just like what do you what why
would you provoke the joker
i guess logic makes no sense like you it
would make more sense if you said it'd
be like married being married to batman
because at least like batman he would
have criminals like threatening like his
girlfriends and his family and like
alfred and [ __ ] like that but like who
was who was like leaving
threatening emails and reddit posts to
the joker yo it's not about the kicks b
it's about making a point poppy
it's about making them it's about making
a point papa papa yes that's the money
on fire
he sets a pile of new jordans on fire
[Laughter]
sorry
toxic it's it's [ __ ] basically
terrorist threats it's crazy yeah man
you're talking about some real i've
never been on the receiving end end of
this insanity and i know a lot of people
have but it's like
whoa whoa guys whoa i had a i yelled at
a friend of mine on the phone there's
somebody i'd known a long time who i
love you know how i got this cauliflower
here
one day
i'm reviewing a food truck in los
angeles
and all of a sudden a fentanyl addicted
homeless mexican
punched me in the ear
[Laughter]
i and i immediately when i i believed
him i go i believe you and i i tried to
call wanna see me make this criticism
video of me disappear
i like how brian's like you know and
then i realized i was wrong yeah kind of
like the way walter white did after he
shot mike yeah spoiler alert yeah and
then he goes oh geez mike i just
realized i could just look at that list
of names from lydia
[Laughter]
leave me alone walt
[ __ ] off wall let me die in peace
[ __ ] what a great show paul as soon
as you spoke to me i know you've covered
it i know i don't know all you can do
brother i know you're breaking papa over
here this is so good freaking papa yeah
you've covered it those people that i
have the taxes i know the taxes have
done all that here's my thing with this
you've done that you've said your piece
you know those extremists are looking
for reasons to to bring you extremists
extremists there's extremists what are
they ecw fans yeah you down or bring us
down and bring them down you don't love
him more than i do yeah i'm a bigger fan
than i am but you just can't focus on
that you know what i'm saying like
you've said your piece now it's up to
them to decide what they want to do with
it yeah that's it yeah come to me come
after me don't don't threaten my family
come on guys don't scare the [ __ ] out of
a woman who's got a baby at home please
come on that's that's this is where it
gets [ __ ] crazy tower i agree with
that you shouldn't do that i mean i 100
percent agree with that but
regardless of you know brian calling he
had a fight with bobby irregardless
irregardless i apologize papa
um
but
but
my my issue is is okay but he's making
it sound like no we're fans i just
texted him now and then you watch tiger
belly he's like i wouldn't even say that
fucker's name you know it's like all
right well there's a difference then
for me fine and again we've squashed
this we we have squashed this that's my
i love that guy i love that guy okay so
it was a phone call i yelled at a friend
bad news i understand but but if it was
so but if it was just yelling at a
friend and a phone call why did this
have to go on h3's podcast why are we
even here then because it must have been
something you said that was so bad that
he was like enough you know mm-hmm
we're good we're good let's move on
yeah let's yeah i bet you want to move
on you know what
let's
we're going to keep an eye on it of
course
but we probably should
because the rest of it is just them you
know doing what they do on their show